[Music]
everyone this is kevin from the chess
website calm and today we're gonna be
going over the elephant trap and it
comes from the queen's gambit declined
lines and we're gonna take a look at it
and kind of go over what side what both
sides are thinking during the trap and
how its executed so it starts out with
pawn to d4 black's gonna respond pawn to
d5 why it's going to transpose into the
Queen's Gambit line which is pawn to c4
and blacks going to decline the line and
that's pawn to e6 obviously he can
decline it a lot of different ways this
is one of the ways you can just pawn to
e6 from here a lot of times you're just
gonna see white develop his knight to
his most most active square which is c3
and from here we're gonna develop our
Knight to f6 trying to defend this d5
pawn obviously he's attacking it twice
down so we want to continue to defend
and a lot of times from here you're
gonna see white bring his Bishop to g5
pinning our knight to the Queen and this
position I just kind of want to go over
kind of goes along with the trap but to
just an idea that you want to think
about in any of your games a lot of
beginners will do a simple move let's
say h6 they want to get rid of this this
pin here but what they don't understand
is that
yes they can trade off pieces here but
Black has two options here he can either
have isolated ponds by taking here which
is never really good especially on the
kingside early in the game most people
are going to Castle kingside so early on
to double your pawns on the kingside is
kind of tough
also if black recaptures on f6 then y
can simply come in and capture on d5 and
then if black recaptures then White's
going to be up in material right away so
yes it's it's simple in the fact that it
looks easy just to do a move like h6 but
you really got to look a little deeper
into the game and figure out what your
opponent's going for so your opponent
even though he's playing Bishop to g5
he's actually attacking the d5 pawn so
from here black has a lot of different
options that you'll normally see one of
the most common is just taking the pawn
on c4 and taking away his weakness on d5
here another one you'll see is just
Bishop to e7 but we're actually going to
go over the elephant trap and the trap
is laid by playing Knight to d7
obviously we're
putting another defender on this night
on f6 but at the same time we've taken
away a defender with our queen that was
looking down at the the d5 pawn so if
white looks at this he's going to think
that he has numbers to take an extra an
extra pawn here and that's gonna look
like this if white captures on d5 we can
recapture and whites simply gonna think
he can come in before he couldn't come
in and capture with this Knight because
our Queen was here but since we've
blocked off our Queen setting the trap
here white thinks he can just come in
and take because white feels that his
the Black Knight is pinned here and he's
not going to move and lose his queen but
in fact we're going to do just that
we're going to take this knight on d5
and we're going to allow the trap to be
set up and allow white to hang himself
here and here's what's gonna happen
obviously it's gonna be a real tempting
and if white does capture then we're
simply going to bring our Bishop to b4
check the king there's only one move
that white has and that's simply to
bring his Queen to d2 and we can from
here capture and then when white
recaptures we can recapture the bishop
on da
so obviously white has his king out in
the open and he is down in material we
have three of our minor pieces yes two
he has one more pawn than we do but we
have more active pieces and our King is
in a little safer position so all in all
we are in much better position and it's
all because we set a little trap that
why thought he could get an extra pawn
at the beginning when in fact he could
not so if you're playing the Queens
gambit declined lines and you want to
spring this trap on someone it works
brilliantly so try it out in two games
let me know how it went hope you guys
enjoyed this video if you haven't
already please subscribe and I'll see
you guys next video thanks for watching
everybody